hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Zeno of Elea is a pre-socratic
philosopher best known for his paradoxes
of motion he was a student of Parmenides
who was a monist who held that
everything is one that being and thought
are identical or the same and that
motion or change was actually an
illusion and what we learned from
plato's Parmenides from the introduction
of it is that Zeno also wrote a treatise
and his treatise was defending
Parmenides point of view but doing it by
way of trying to show that any
assumption that motion or change really
exists or takes place leads us into
paradoxes that is it leads us into
contradictions things that don't seem to
make sense now we unfortunately don't
have xenos treatise it's supposed to
have contained a number of different
arguments but we do have the
reconstructions available from later
philosophers who were largely
criticizing Zeno for these paradoxes
that he's presenting and among them is
Aristotle who tells us you know quite a
bit about why these are wrong and what
the problem is which will get
- in just a moment but he also lays out
for us what the paradoxes are supposed
to be and they're kind of ingenious so
you might want to think about them a
little bit and ponder them before you
immediately say oh that that doesn't
work at all and just let the paradox
itself sink in so there's four of them
the dichotomy it's usually called the
Achilles sometimes called Achilles and
the tortoise the arrow and the stadium
all of them are intended to show that if
you assume that motion exists we're
going to be led into some sort of
problem so the conclusion should be that
well motion doesn't really exist
so the dichotomy is fairly
straightforward
imagine that you have to traverse some
sort of area and it's finite in length
so you have to go from here to the train
station or you need to cross the room or
you just need to cross this portion of
chalk on the chalkboard so in order to
get there you have to go at least half
way so we can mark out a halfway point
good job you're already halfway there
right that's the good news
now the bad news is you can do the same
thing for every other part of this
interval so you know you've made it
halfway you can go three quarters of the
way wow you're really making a lot of
progress and now you can divide that
portion further and now you've got seven
eighths and we go on and on and on
and Zino's argument says you never
actually reach the final limit point
because for any interval that you're
looking at you can always draw another
division within it you can always
dichotomize it that is cut it in half so
given that you will never actually cross
that that line at the end and you'll
never finish up with your path the
Achilles is actually very similar to
this except it has two different objects
moving one is Achilles the fastest of
runner
is back in the you know the host that
attacked Troy and then by convention the
other one is a turtle quite slow and a
tortoise
right and so Achilles gives the tortoise
a head start he says you know I'm gonna
catch you sooner or later so let's give
you a really good head start and then
the you know the flag drops or the gun
goes off and they start running right
and the turtle doesn't run that far and
Achilles catches up to where the turtle
started but in that time the turtle has
moved on someone he has crossed some
territory and now Achilles crosses that
next territory where the tortoise was
and he almost catches him but the
tortoise has moved on as well and we can
keep doing this over and over again by
the time that he gets there the tortoise
is going a little bit further by the
time that he gets there the tortoise is
gone yet a little bit further and you
know we can imagine these getting
infinitesimally small so Achilles will
never catch the tortoise the fastest
runner will never catch the slowest
runner you can see that these are
actually according to you know aerosol
tells us these are actually identical in
the respect that they both have to do
with traversing the same amount of space
so they're not really fundamentally
different problems the arrow is a
different problem this has to do with a
sort of metaphysical issue of motion and
rest so imagine that you're shooting an
arrow at any given point in time
you've got the arrow and you know here
it is there you go good enough so we're
imagining it at a number of different
points as its flying right first it's
here then it's there then it's there at
any given point that we think about it
the arrow occupies the same space that
is equal to its size but there's a
problem that is exactly what it means to
be at rest to be occupying a space for
you know the brief duration of a moment
so while it's in motion
it's also
at rest it is at rest at every single
point in its motion that's paradoxical
isn't it because rest and motion are
supposed to be opposites to each other
so that seems to be a bit of a problem
if we go on a little bit further the
stadium is a little bit trickier a
little bit more complex and we have to
reconstruct it with a diagram sort of
like this imagine trains that might be
the easiest way to do it or cars or
whatever it is that you want to do the
point is is that you've got this length
right here a and let's say these are
spectators and then you've got something
moving call it B and it's composed of
points and some of it overlaps with a
and then we also have a similar thing C
overlapping partly with a not
overlapping at all with B at the start
and moving in the opposite direction
here's where the paradox arises
according to Zeno so b traverses two
squares let's call them right two units
B is moving two units this way C is
moving two units this way and that's in
relation to a but how much to B and C
move in relation to each other for so
something is moving both two and four
units at the same time that seems to be
a contradiction a thing has to move the
amount that it moves right it can't be
moving double the amount that it's
moving because then it would just be
moving double the amount that it was
moving and it would be moving at a
different speed so it seems like it's
going at two different speeds or rates
covering two different amounts of ground
at the same time now are there solutions
to these yes of course Aristotle himself
says you know the claim with the
Achilles the claim is that the slowest
runner will never be caught by the
fastest runner this is the same argument
as the dichotomy with the difference at
the mass
remaining is not divided in half we've
seen that the argument entails the
slower slower runners not caught but
this depends on the same point as the
dichotomy what is that point in both
cases the conclusion it's impossible to
reach a limit is a result of dividing
the magnitude the distance in a certain
way but what's not being taken account
of time when you're going this far it's
taking that amount of time and then it
takes half the amount of time and half
the amount of time so sooner or later
you will in fact traverse the entire
length of the dichotomy sooner or later
Achilles will in fact catch the tortoise
that's not a big problem
right when it comes to the arrow he says
that the conclusion depends on assuming
that time is composed of nows of moments
of moments that could be isolated apart
from each other and Aristotle says if
you take that away then the argument
fails it doesn't say that you have to
take it away but he says that if you do
take it away it fails the stadium is a
little bit more complicated he says that
the results of the argument is that half
a given time is equal to double the time
the mistake in his reasoning lies in
supposing that it takes the same time
for one moving body to move past a body
in motion as it does for another to move
past a body at rest where both are the
same size as each other and moving at
the same speed and this is false so if
there's no problem once we actually
bring time into it in accounting for
that it this is just what it means for
two bodies to be in motion in relation
to each other so each of these paradoxes
is you know an interesting little dice
cursus into you know what it means to
move and you know how distance would be
involved and what happens when we take
time out as a factor or we look at time
in in terms of moments in a kind of
unusual way all of them fail as
paradoxes but they're all well worth
looking at because we want to know why
they don't work not just that they don't
work and that tells us something a
little bit about how motion which you
know Aristotle and so many other
philosophers think is real would in fact
function so permenant partner Parmenides
uh he was his teacher Zeno is trying to
make these arguments of which we only
have you know a few unfortunately to
support this notion that there is no
change there is no motion but when I
turned you know when we look at it it
turns out that there actually can be
motion and these paradoxes as arguments
fail
you